in this video we'll talk about cortisol
aka the stress hormone cortisol is
secreted by the adrenal glands present
on the kidneys and this is a steroid
hormone
cortisol helps our body to fight stress
that's why it is also known as a stress
hormone let's talk about the functions
cortisol is relevant and important for
body's response towards stress other
than that it regulates metabolism
it suppresses inflammation and regulates
blood sugar level these are the major
functions of cortisol
let's talk about the biosynthesis of
cortisol it's a steroid hormone so it
would be synthesized from cholesterol
now it's not that straightforward
cholesterol gets converted to
intermediates like pregnenolone
eventually it gets converted to seven
hydroxy progesterone and then ultimately
in sequential step it gets converted to
cortisol so overall it's a cholesterol
derivative
now if we look at the adrenal cortex
there are three different layers Zona
glomerulus granulosa Zona fasciculata
and Zona reticularis
so the outer layer secretes
mineralocorticoid the inner layer
secretes
um the androgens and the middle layer
the Zona fasciculata secretes
glucocorticoids like cortisol
so the secretion of cortisol follows a
diuronal pattern that means it has
higher secretion during the days and
lower secretion during the night
cortisol secretion is regulated by a
hormonal axis so first
the corticotropine releasing hormone
from the hypothalamus
instruct the pituitary to secrete ACTH
ACTH acts on the adrenal gland to
secrete the cortisol when cortisol
levels are abruptly high in the blood
there would be a negative feedback which
would act on pituitary for short term
and for a longer term it would act on
the hypothalamus to reduce the level of
crh and ACTH this is how a nice
secretion Loop is maintained
let's talk about the biological actions
of cortisol in bit more details
cortisol can act on various tissues
majorly it works on liver adipose
tissues and muscle
in the liver cortisol ensures that
glycogen lysis takes place
so glucose level would be increasing in
an action of cortisol it also prevents
the formation of glycogen from glucose
now in adipose tissue cortisol ensures
that fatty acids are freed up from the
fat and these can be utilized to
generate energy
and in muscles it breaks down proteins
to form peptides in short form it
activates catabolic responses and
suppresses anabolism
and think about this in this way when
your body is undergoing stress it needs
energy so it needs all building block
that can produce energy cortisol ensures
body has enough amount of energy when it
needs
now cortisol level in the blood Rises
during stress and when we are under
stress
cortisol ensures that other organs like
liver muscle does not take up glucose
and this would result in an increase in
blood glucose level which can be
channeled towards our brain and our
brain should be active in this kind of
Crisis moment
in the liver it also ensures glycogen
can be broken down and glucose can be
increased in the blood also amino acids
can be converted to glucose via new
glucogenesis so moral of the story
cortisol increases the blood glucose
concentration
so simply to put it cortisol antagonize
the work of insulin
another major work of cortisol is to
suppress the immune system
and it kind of regulate the balance
between inflammation and risk of
infection because it decreases the risk
of inflammation but also increases the
risk of infection by other organism
so it's a potent immunosuppressant
now cortisol is useful after a graft
grafting
uh surgery so let's say this is a tissue
graft and this tissue graft can be
rejected by the host and that is why
your immune system need to be suppressed
generally the doctors prescribe cortisol
injections which prevents or suppress
the immune system to reject this kind of
graft
so cortisol actually inhibits the
inflammatory mediators and several
inflammatory cytokines such as like
interferon gamma tnf Alpha
Etc and it also promote the formation of
interleukin 10 which is an
anti-inflammatory cytokine
so moral of the story cortisol is an
immunosuppressant and it reduces
inflammation by producing
anti-inflammatory cytokines
when it comes to Bone formation cortisol
impedes the bone formation by increasing
the osteoclast activity
and it prevents the osteoblast activity
so let's talk about the molecular
mechanism of cortisol action cortisol is
a steroid derivative so it can easily
pass through the membrane and it can
bind to intracellular receptors The
receptors for cortisol are present in
the cytoplasm but
when the ligand is not bound it was
bound to a heat shock protein which gets
removed when the cortisol binds to it
eventually it moves to the nucleus
dimerize and it can activate several
genes responsible for glucose metabolism
protein catabolism and fat metabolism
now when there is a very high level of
cortisol in blood it's not really good
because there are several conditions
such as the Cushing syndrome where you
have abnormally high level of cortisol
it can cause problem other reasons of
high cortisol in blood might be due to
adrenal gland tumors which is
overproducing cortisol also when you
take corticosteroids that might lead to
an increase in the blood cortisol levels
so as per summary we looked at the
important functions of cortisol and how
it regulates physiology as a take-home
message I should say
cortisol is an potent immunosuppressant
and it has a widespread effect on
metabolism overall it promotes
catabolism breaking down of glucose
breaking down of protein and breaking
down of fat and it ensures our body has
the source of energy when it needs the
most under stress situation right and
also it works as an with a intracellular
receptor so it can lead to several gene
expression changes you can get more
notes and flashcards in my Facebook page
you can also follow us on Instagram
links are in the description you can
support our Channel by super thanks you
can pay via paytm Paypal UPI see you in
next video